okay I think we're gonna get started
this evening thank you all for coming
I'm Mabel Wilson and I direct the
advanced architectural research program
here at the GSA pp and one of the things
we should remember is that architects
not only design these days but they're
also essentially responsible for
developing new forms of expertise
leading the field in the innovation and
experimentation GSA peepees Research
Laboratories focus on three interrelated
initiatives and I think this is some of
what you'll see from the five labs out
of I think roughly 15 labs in the school
that have to do with the development of
new technologies and fabrication methods
cultural analysis of local and global
conditions the investigation of
urbanization and its environmental and
social impacts to more directly involve
these research laboratories in the
educational mission of the school GSA pp
office a program in advanced
architectural research aar for recent
graduates who work with faculty and lab
directors on a one-year Applied Research
Projects so this has been happening
basically for the last three years the
labs offer a platform for the exchange
of innovative ideas and for
collaboration between the different labs
fields of expertise tonight we will hear
from the lab directors who will discuss
the role of research in the various
institutional what I would call food
groups of the GSA PP which is
architecture planning and urban design
now for advancing architectural research
2.0 because we did a similar event last
year that involved China lab and C lab I
thought it would be useful to shift the
focus on what the labs do which was what
they discussed last year to really how
do the labs work in research you know
one of the questions we might ask is
research a form of practice or is it
markedly different does practice because
of its prospective nature already engage
in research
tonight each lab director will briefly
discuss the methods and influences on
how he/she conducts the the labs
initiatives through one or more projects
we have asked them to also consider if
they have adopted research methodologies
from for instance engineering from
computer science the social sciences art
practices new media and so forth
more importantly we want them to
consider how are these techniques
adopted two methods of architectural
design to hybridize new methodologies of
investigation one key question in all of
this is if through this cross
fertilization these new hybrid forms of
research offer new modes and models of
inquiry to other disciplines fields and
practices so we will hear from five of
the GSA PP labs tonight Phil Angeloni
is the director of Building Technologies
at the GSA pp he directs the new
initiative C BIP and directs the Avery
digital fabrication lab with Scott
marble the Fab Lab has made a shift
toward expansive forms of digital
production within the design and
construction industry this recalibration
of goals affords the opportunity of not
only reconfiguring the relationships
between the key players but also
incorporating industry sectors not
typically associated with building
construction Toro Hasegawa directs the
newly formed cloud lab with Mark Collins
together they also had proxy which is an
innovation focused design firm that
works across a range of scales and
platforms Toro has worked as an
architect in New York City in Tokyo
since founding proxy in 2006 with mark
Tory has worked to explore the
potentials within the computational
paradigm for a range of clients from
individuals to institutions and
including the aforementioned fab labs
and other labs within the school the
urban landscape lab is dedicated to
effecting positive social and ecological
change in the joint built natural
environment we will be joined by Janette
Kim who is
architectural designer in educator based
in New York she is also a principal of
all of the above and architectural
research and design practice
Jeanette's practice research and
teaching focus on the construction of
Ecology's in relationship to
representations of public identity we
are also along with Jeanette joined by
urban labs other director Kate North who
is a registered architect an active
design practitioner in her office scape
she leads studios and seminars at the
GSA PP that integrate the earth sciences
into the design curriculum Sarah
Williams co-directs the spatial
information design lab with Laura kurgan
before coming to the GSA pp Sarah was at
MIT where she started the GIS laboratory
she's also worked with MIT sensible
since Abel sorry his City laboratory
which is a joint program between MIT
Media Lab and department of urban
studies and planning Sarah has 13 years
of experience with GIS dating back to
her early work with Clark labs and the
Idris project and lastly Columbia's
anomalies Columbia's moving image lab is
directed by filmmaker and architect
mother and Ratna m-- in addition to the
lab mother mr. director of Alton in Oh
studio and a PhD research candidate in
the School of Architecture and design at
RMIT University in Australia milk a
project-based research lab explores the
role of film and animation in
architecture and design well-versed in
the debates around design research
mother taught this year's aar research
methodologies course and has graciously
agreed to moderate the discussion for
this evening's panel so thank you for
coming and let the games begin
see this work
all right okay hello everyone my name is
Philip Anzalone digital fabrication lab
sorry and the idea of showing how we
work through me a little bit because
usually in the fabrication lab we show
what we've done right it's about making
something so I want to talk a little bit
about you know show a little of what
we've done but but jump into what how we
work and showing a couple projects that
we've done where we go and actually
build something someplace else in the
world that's a so you know you know what
we do we have a lot of sort of advanced
software of course as everybody does and
GSEP
we play with a lot of cool materials
some very new materials and different
types of systems we have to construct a
lot of large things and of course we
have the machinery which is what
everybody you know wants to play around
with but you know I have to be very
careful to make sure that it's being
played around with well and this is an
interesting image because I think that
this is really right there so if you
want to see this image in its glory you
can go over the fabrication lab the the
idea of the hand I think is kind of
interesting in the concept of digital
fabrication this is where I want to kind
of want to go with with a little bit of
this discussion you know the hand has a
long history of course architecture and
so on this is what the hand you should
look like a fabrication lab so I want to
show a few projects that we've done in
the lab in different methods you know
research student work and so on you'll
notice there's always the the pretty
object right and then and then how it
you know how it has to be done right
how we were yes right everybody seems
happy there's Tohru gotcha usually it's
me standing around right this time I got
and there's some examples that are still
around today sometimes it's a single
person sometimes it's more sometimes
we're doing things we're not supposed to
be doing in the school sometimes things
are not quite all that digitally
fabricated sometimes it's dangerous and
basically usually involves a lot of
people right sometimes it's a small
amount but for larger projects there's a
lot of people what I want to talk about
is a couple of projects we've done very
quickly related to trips that we do we
go abroad and we build something with
another school this is the first one in
Torino and then we also did one that
you'll see in Madrid the interesting
thing about that and the reason why it's
it struck me is what I should show for
how we work is the goal behind it is
that it's not just about digital
fabrication in other words the computer
having the design work fed into it and
then it prints out something in a way
right it's not about letting the machine
actually takeover has a lot to do with
people in fact a lot of these projects a
lot of this doesn't even involve any
digital fabrication all becomes a bit
construction right so we went to Torino
this is the School of Architecture very
nice we were a little jealous after that
this was the bike I rode around Torino
right since it's gonna be a little bit
of a show of our trip what happened is
basically you know we get somebody to
donate material we get somebody to
donate a space in an event and so on and
then we go and build something right at
these locations and and it's a little
bit different than digitally fabricated
we deal with the same concepts right
parametric's surprisingly and you don't
have to digitally output them we deal
with a lot of solid modelling a lot of
analysis and so forth in different ways
as you'll see we all get together and
build stuff and take a look at it the
same way you would do on the computer
same way you do on the machine
except it's a lot of times by hand Robby
was surprised that caught him in the act
standing around you know we build
examples right take them outside see how
they look in the context and then this
is the location that in this case we
were building an info center so we're
building a pavilion for an event it's
the World Design Capital this was in
Italy that was let's say 12 Italian
students 12 US students and a few from
other places around the world this is
Italy in a summer right so we learn a
lot about the fact that you have to stay
in the shade so everybody's over here on
the side but finally somebody has to get
to work and this is typical of anything
so Ingrid finally picked up the first
piece and everybody got to work digital
prints a little bit of analog work right
it's not all digital but there's digital
involved and all kinds of fabrication as
well I was sitting in the Sun I'm not
sure who that is but eventually we come
up with some detailing that has to deal
with how we would create something with
the same sort of effect that we talked
about this is really a two week project
were there for two weeks only the same
sort of effect that we've that we've
used for a lot of the digital
fabrication projects that come straight
from the machinery but if you notice
there's a lot of handwork this is a I
think it's an interesting project or set
of projects because it allows people to
understand how the machine does exactly
what you would do just faster
differently more precise and so on so we
start building things right it's going
in taking photos so this was the you
know this was the pavilion as it was
working but then you know we get onto
what we learn in these kind of locations
like how to work at night right because
they did not have any lights at our
location how to work Italian style I
suppose how to roll up our shirts like
us construction workers so we can show
the Italians and we had a nice large
location where we were able to give our
presentation which we don't have here in
the US or at least in New York right
going on to Madrid at this location what
happened is this was the second event
that we did with the fabrication lab so
we started to play a little bit of an
idea about how we could how we could
engage with the culture how we could
deal with how things are constructed
differently how the material is
different in another location and so on
so this is where how we work sort of
started to gel as far as the idea of
what these summer workshops would be
Torino was the first one it was an
experiment in sorts we still had bikes
right
you may recognize some of the people
because it's getting closer to our year
and we all we all went the same way sat
down started to do design work in paper
same way as we do here as well and then
started to become more digital as things
as things proceeded an interesting thing
that this this involves is the idea that
a lot of the fabrication projects that
we've dealt with have to do of course
with computational files right and a lot
of the methods of production and so on
and a lot of this gets split up and
brought together into different groups
of you're working on a project together
of course on a large project you
understand how you separate the work how
you bring it all back together how you
deal with this with the computer it's no
different when you're doing this by hand
in a way and then it is when you're
doing this digitally with digital
fabrication I guess I should say right
so we had the same the same issues when
you get to the material you have to pick
it up you have to move it around you
have to get out the saw cut things up
play around with it lay things out for
have discussions right about what we're
doing and so I'll go back to the drawing
board as the old phrase goes right
eventually come up with well they were a
little clunky at first the details but
started to play around with how to make
these things right completely out of the
computer to our hands in a way and not
necessarily through all of the machinery
there's Luke lifting and then we all had
to join in on the game right so the idea
is exactly the same the production is is
relatively similar but we learned a lot
about the precision and the method
of dividing up how things work in these
in these workshops right so it was an
exhibit for for Museum so we eventually
clad it just the same way as as we do in
those project and the head tapas right
but a few things that we're interesting
about this this is this is a a very
important point that I learned in Spain
they vote about everything had no idea
of why but I just didn't I just didn't
quite understand it being as we always
say we're the democracy right in the
world it's not it really true we had to
vote about every move we made so it was
a it became very interesting that you
know here's our voting right this is
architecture by voting very interesting
method of production right so this is a
new way of working for me which usually
you know we don't vote on the computer
right it's more than drinking we learned
how to cut things a little differently
and here we're drinking and and as you
can see it's all by hand again I showed
all of the digital stuff previously and
I'll show some more at the end we
learned about the Vitruvius man we
learned a little bit of self-defense how
to break things if you don't have any
any machines to break them with and how
to be careful that you don't cut your
hand off right so there's still a lot of
danger involved in all of this
so I guess to sort of wrap up is very
quick presentation and and if anybody
has questions of course will be free to
ask in order to answer them at the end
one thing that all of this has taught a
lot of us that work on these is in a way
the difference between between the
digital the precision of the digital and
the imprecision of the hand which or the
body or whatever we want to call it
which i think is very interesting right
some of these projects that we've done
that showed at the beginning of the
presentation have have a degree of
precision that the only way to really
get them to work is to break out the
hammer and actually start like forcing
them to go together right there's a lot
of things that are incorrect it's hard
to keep track of all this stuff even
with the computer a lot of problems a
lot of missing things a lot of Bend
pieces that should have been astray
right a lot of things are just plain
wrong right so nonetheless all of this
digital fabrication has the ability to
go drastically wrong even with the
precision and the amount of tracking
that you can do so in a way I guess you
know to sum it up in my 11 minute martha
is I think that the we're we're I'm
looking at some of the study in the lab
itself is how we can merge the concepts
of you know this digital completely non
touched fabrication and then how we
actually go about building things I
guess that's it
I'm Tory I'm directing this with Mark
Collins we're also actually starting the
Abbott texture visual studies class this
second half of this semester
it just started literally in talking
this semester so I don't have as much
light as Phil does but I'll go one by
one of my three three slides now we we
all kind of know computers are
everywhere right like there's one right
here in front of me I have the iPhone
even your refrigerator or even your you
know microwave has a computer in some
way or another now it's the ubiquitous
networking or ubiquitous computing is
this kind of notion that computer was
pretty much be in anything and we won't
even kind of understand that it's a
different entity of of us so it could be
in your clothes it can be in our glasses
it can be pretty much in anything now
that said the mission of this kind of
computer lab is somewhat to kind of
expand that conversation of this kind of
where how do we think of this kind of
new kind of reality we're engaged in
where we can access information or we
can access in in some sense all this
resource right so the good example being
the folding at home project by Stanford
University where it would tap into all
Playstations around the world to kind of
reach a petaflop speed of which
supercomputers can't even reach so this
kind of interesting condition where you
know computers are out there can kind of
gang together and become the fastest
computer so the access point to this
kind of many computers is somewhat this
this cloud right we understand this
cloud is this kind of collective of of
computers that are just it there to be
kind of consumed in a sense or even used
and another strategy where
I would say that was use is like in
Obama campaign like there was no other
way of distributing a kind of quantity
of information or communication rather
through this cloud so kind of knowing
the cloud is the kind of new new kind of
front or let's say we can even say it's
the new space that we should be starting
to explore into or being able to kind of
think of in that spaciality of beyond
the three dimension or in this kind of
multiple dimension another example of
that is is the kind of DARPA
initiative competition called the
networked computer network challenge
where you would the competition in
itself was to be asked there was going
to be 10 red balloons being launched
somewhere in the United States not
knowing when it was going to be launched
and the first group to find all was the
winner
now the winner being a group from MIT
called the human dynamics lab launched
its own kind of I call it the Facebook
plus microfinance strategy where it
would make its own network of saying if
you find it you get $2,000 if you were a
agent in the network that referenced
that person you get $1,000 and so forth
so that network strategy with finance
was the capitate captivating strategy to
find all 10 now the extent of the lab is
that we do gauge in the scale of
software now that that is where you're
able to communicate in this cloud and
being able to kind of use that kind of
resource in in kind of any context right
so these are all context that I just
gave example but for our cloud lab here
at gzip is to really think well what
does that mean for architects and
architectural design for space now we
can kind of bring the the concept of
computing in the sense that now we're
still used to kind of having our
personal computers in front of us and we
use it to design but once that that kind
of personal interface is not the kind of
case that it is or you victory to see
out there
it becomes a software problem of how do
you kind of just almost kind of have a
dialog between the kind of cloud you
have in yourself so our our strategy
here is to kind of gauge into this kind
of software platform through mobile apps
in to kind of give the first example now
I show this slide that it is really
fresh we were just trying to develop it
we still have many ideas on the table
kind of including what to consider
obviously many of the thoughts also
include like supercomputing where when
our resource of power on speed is beyond
our usual computer right when you can
add thousands computers all together and
start problem solving that is a kind of
entry point to our problem
and lastly let me just show this is
somewhat a real to kind of indicate what
kind of research were kind of trying to
focus on is well just taking this
example of the mobile phone where if you
can already kind of augment Li know
where you are what direction you're
looking at keep that data tracking it
already opens up this kind of spatial
problem for us that we've been always
gauging of engaging as a kind of
architectural problem but actually
having that power through software to
actually even construct it distribute it
and even kind of data mined through that
information so that is the kind of
extent I'll just kind of wait until this
ends but the the kind of focal point
again is kind of this media or this
let's say new spatial terrain that the
cloud where as architects we have to
kind of start thinking of what is
potentially possible because it is
somewhat unkind of explored terrain for
us so we're kind of putting that onto
the table and and we're we're kind of
already kind of partnering ship with a
few people including including kensaku
Moreau which is probably one of the
most pioneered person in this kind of
operating system business where he was
already thinking in the 70s 80s of
thinking of well once once we have
computing power and everything
everything will converse with everything
so as humans we would just become a part
of that ecology of objects so not only
you speaking to object objects would be
speaking to objects so this is all
through this kind of medium of software
so that's probably the best description
I can give at this point so our research
are initially starting this semester of
already thinking of well what is a GCS
app now we're kind of calling it the app
for the school where we're just
launching this semester is to really
think of well what is the media the
school can start engaging in this cloud
what are what are the issues that we can
bring up and what are the kind of things
we can start kind of computing so this
is cloud lab and I guess the extent is
that people will kind of start joining
the end over of the research and a part
of that initiative we start this app
texture as well thank you
okay hi I'm Kate orff and this is
Jeanette Kim and we're co directors of
the urban landscape lab and so well I
mean I guess it's pretty self-evident
from our mission statement but we're
really interested in looking at the city
through the lens of of landscape and and
kind of studying this kind of complex
network of ecological processes and
social issues that together form the
diversity and biodiversity and social
diversity of cities and our work really
has been diverse in terms of its
methodology and output and Jeanette's
gonna talk a little bit about the
methodology but before we get to that I
thought it might be just interesting to
see a cross-section of the past work our
collaborations have kind of included
things like the bird safe design
guidelines a sort of set of design
guidelines that led towards
incorporating bird safe ideas into a
LEED potential lead point that were
accepted by the Audubon Society a report
with the spatial information design lab
about Gateway National Recreation Area a
Charette for the city of New York which
is called this is Newark and you know
things like aquaponic prototyping and
and and basically Jeanette and I are
also now working on combining the work
of our studios and seminars towards
generating sort of new forms of
educational dialogue and research and I
guess with that went oh I wanted to say
importantly though that I think may be
very very important for our lab is also
this notion of collaboration and
actually the network of people who work
with us because and very important to us
is this notion that in order to kind of
create cultural change which I know that
sounds kind of crazy but but you know in
order to like engage with the world you
actually have to build a sort of
networks of dialogue and so not only an
intelligence that exists within the
school but one
it's constantly sort of interfacing with
you know the sort of realities of New
York City and city agencies and so on so
a lot of it of our interest is that this
exists at this intersection of sort of
research within the Academy and an
interface with the institutions and so
on that makeup and the larger city so
kate and i decided to focus our talk
today mostly on safari 7 and we'd like
to introduce the project to you and talk
a bit about the research methods that
that really brings to the discussion and
i think in many ways the project is what
we'd like to really focus on is this
idea that research isn't sort of just
the process of observation but is also
really a process of outreach and is a
process that kind of builds up ways of
collaborating and ways of joining
knowledge together so as a brief
introduction safari 7 is a project that
focuses on animal life along the number
7 train line here in new york city and
the project distributes podcasts and and
maps along the seven line that were
intended to be used on the train as a
kind of kind of park ranger or as a kind
of mobile tour of the city
the project really focuses on the kind
of biodiversity of the city that often
goes under recognized and really focuses
on this idea that animal life and the
ecosystems of the city are not just
things that happen within parks or
fringes of the city but are really
things that happen right in your
backyard really right in your kitchen
right sort of the most intimate spaces
of the city we really focus on this idea
of the mashup which is a way of kind of
linking animals to each other in ways
that we might not always see and also is
ways of kind of linking human life to
animal life so just for a couple of
example some of our podcasts and
Maps focus for example on mutant island
here in the East River which was created
from landfill or from rebel from the
number 7 train steinway tunnel
construction and sort of created this
whole chain reaction of bird life on the
island which is itself also influenced
by levels of DDT that have been changing
throughout New York's Harbor or in
another example we look at Flushing
Meadows and this kind of arrests a
really surprising kind of network of
reactions stemming from the cold old old
use of this land as an ash dump moving
on to Robert Moses is kind of grant
grand master plan for the site and
moving on to really unexpected kind of
new clashes of animal life ranging from
the kind of amazingly bizarre
Frankenfish that can survive for like I
forget eight hours out of water
to this kind of clash of geese and
airplanes that we heard of with the US
Air airplane crashed in the Hudson last
year so really the concept of the
project is to use the subway itself as
the site for exploration and we really
focus on this idea of kind of using the
car as a kind of eco classroom as this
kind of place for where you sort of
become a park ranger and both kind of
observe and direct new tourists through
the city so really in order to do this
we sort of had to become Park Rangers
ourselves and as Kate mentioned Safari 7
is is very much a team effort a lot of
the podcasts began in the Barnard
Columbia undergraduate program of
architecture where I teach a seminar on
urban ecology and a lot of the podcasts
came from students working there and in
many ways safari 7 is it kind of adopts
this kind of frame of journalistic
research we we do our own background
research to every podcast but we also
really make sure to form new knowledge
by speaking with people doing interviews
kind of gathering knowledge
that people have of neighborhoods and
combining them with knowledge that
scientists have so this is an example of
Lisa Ecklie going on a trip with Stephen
handle through Sunnyside yards where he
he did a kind of podcast walk of weed
life and plant life along this kind of
abandoned site and this is also a tour
that Helen Khan's guard one of our team
members did with James denaburg who's a
ecologist who explained kind of mass
studies that he and his students did
throughout the city like laying down
traps to see how insects were gathering
at different places
understanding how ants live along
highway medians so he really explored
explain not only his research but his
research methods as well and this
expands in a number of directions where
this is a young Safari 17 member who
some of you might recognize who decided
he got so excited about the project that
he decided to make his own and for the
number one train so we start to have
kind of new mappings emerge out of the
project and we're starting to run some
education projects with some local
education groups in Queens and and I
think this really gets to this kind of
question of citizen science that that
the project becomes a kind of frame to
collect and and kind of instigate
knowledge from people for a wide range
of backgrounds and this is just one
example of a photograph that was sent to
us by this woman Julia sure Chuck who
lives in Jackson Heights and this is a
photograph of this hawk on her on her
fire escape and one of the next steps
also for us is to do a map with Sarah
Williams on mushrooms in the city and
we're collaborating with this group
called Stratus for a group of artists
and mycologists and dancers and chefs
who work on who look at mushroom life in
the city and for me it really raises
this kind of question of the potentials
and also the kind of challenges of
citizen science we're going to connect
to this database called NOAA which is
kind of
has set up a really fantastic interface
with which you can kind of upload
information about animals and this was
sort of my example of like bad cow that
the site's fantastic but this one
example is it as my example of like the
problems of crowdsourcing that we would
find like trees really blurry you know
and it it sort of raises the question if
like the resolution the kind of depth of
knowledge that you can get the amazing
thing though is that through the kind of
comments and added knowledge and kind of
added interest in this idea of kind of
scouting your own city gathering
knowledge and collecting it but I think
these things will change over time and I
think we can really start to build more
precise knowledge as we go well I mean
just to just to build on that idea I
mean now that Safari 7 has has basically
because it it intersects these kind of
two major facets of sustainability that
is sort of public transport and the
environment and ecology that it's really
received a lot of attention I would say
you've heard a lot of different types of
groups and and people and so one of the
things we're interested in in engaging a
our program with is actually
brainstorming with us and brainstorming
with you about the future of this
project this is actually the one of the
manifestations that our work took on in
New York and we were working also with
Glenn Cummings of Mt WTF on this project
in terms of the outreach piece and so we
actually did an installation at Studio X
and here in lower Manhattan of the work
this is an example of a literal mashup
of literally kind of two different well
this is a failed broken mashup but the
the the project included sort of a map
table these sort of sections and mashups
that that talked about they sort of in
you know it collisions if you will of
sort of urban systems and natural
systems and so this is our first kind of
attempt at outreach which is a party and
so we had a really big party
downtown and with the idea that this
Safari 7 Reading Room was essentially
kind of an orientation space where you
can sort of learn about the city
download some podcasts and then go out
and ride the train and take the safari
and so that was a sort of place where
you can get oriented and here's some of
those elements on display and so now
we're again we want to understand you
know what what is the future of safari 7
we have this sort of database and
mapping project and we've also reached
an agreement with the MTA here in New
York to now actually incorporate Safari
7 as their kind of Keystone project for
MTA for Earth Day so we we have a
million metro cards that are being
printed next month and we have an
exhibit now that's going to be up in
Vanderbilt so we're really interested in
reaching out to students and to all of
you to help us lead some tours and and
kind of brainstorm about what that sort
of Earth Day event could be another
direction that's been very exciting for
us in terms of thinking about the future
of this project is how we can take the
frame of Safari 7 and start to engage
other global cities where Columbia is
now establishing a sort of studio-x
presence so I'm sure that the studio-x
will be a topic of great discussion
hopefully when we're up here at the
front but that's another direction that
we're fascinated with it that we really
love to engage students or a our
students with in terms of brainstorming
about how this frame could begin to
engage other cities other environments
and so finally before we close a new
another new initiative of the the lab is
reaching out and working with the Mary
myths studio and if you know the artist
mary miss the environmental artist she's
been working with people in the city of
New York and trying to develop prototype
projects that engage artists and
scientists along Broadway as a kind of
a way of reframing New York City as a
sort of a 21st century sustainable city
so another potential in terms of a our
research next year would be working with
Jeanette and I and also Mary on on that
project so with that we'll close and
look forward to the discussion okay my
name is Sarah Williams and I co-direct
the spatial information design lab with
Laura kurgan and what I thought I would
focus on the talk today is about our
methodology in the lab we asked about
how we work and I think one of the
interesting things about the spatial
information design lab is some of the
methods that we use and our methods are
our methodological put uses data about
places to expose social and
environmental issues that might not have
otherwise been seen and really at the
core of that definition I would say is
the use of data to expose the underlying
systems of the place and so some of the
methods I think that our core methods in
the lab are techniques for collection of
unique data sets unique forms of
analysis particularly spatial analysis
and unique forms of visualization and
when we kind of bring those even further
down we have we use I think what's
really special about some of the
methodological approaches of the lab is
the use of quantitative analysis or
quantitative techniques that you might
find in statistics or social sciences or
quantitative methods combined with
visual reference
and so so in each project that we work
on we really try to think about the
economy between those two and I think
often in data visualization projects you
see just visualization you don't see
kind of the quantitative methods behind
it so I always try to do the statistical
analysis and also do the visualization
so that the hard sciences is gonna look
at our data it makes sense them but it
also looks representational and
interesting so if we take one project
that I think that might explain that the
best and one of the things that Mabel
asked us to do is kind of think about
where you draw your methods from and so
I think one place that we draw a lot of
methods from our from social sciences
and geography I'm a geographer and by
training so that makes a lot of sense
and one project that we often look at a
different phenomenon in space and so one
of the statistics that I employ a lot in
my work is the Geddes org or hot spot
statistic maybe I'll just explain what
that is through approachment so here's a
project that we did which was the
geography of buzz and in this project
this is a this map actually shows the
the hot spot statistic and is showing
that there's a clustering of theater
events in Midtown or what do you think
of as the theater district which makes
sense but what's unique about this
project is that we collected the data
from the Getty image repository so we
actually went into the database scraped
of their information out of the Getty
photos to tell us where events were
happening in the city and we created a
database out of those events and we had
latitude and longitude which is our
spatial points which allowed us to plot
each event and these are all kind of all
the events in New York
city the circles represent how many
photos were taking at different events
so once we had those that data plotted
about arts and culture events in the
city we were able to make maps such as
this that shows us where the events
clusters and what we did is we actually
ran a spatial statistics on this and
this is probably not as interesting to
some people but is really interesting
the social sciences is that we found
using the global brands I statistic that
we had to miss a significant clustering
and different types of Arts and Culture
events which was illustrated through our
different visualization so that's one
way that we use methods and what we
found was that arts and culture events
in New York and Los Angeles tend to
cluster around what people would think
of as iconic architecture in those
spaces so they might not be hotspots of
one of the hotspots that we found is
Times Square in New York how many people
really think of Times Square as a place
to go as New Yorkers so what we found is
that the Getty image database is really
clustering around places that you
iconically think of in those cities so
in New York it was Fifth Avenue Midtown
Times Square in Los Angeles it was
Hollywood Beverly Hills and Sunset Strip
and so what we found by mapping the
places where images were taken we found
out how media represents space and/or
uses architecture as a way to sell
product through the images as I
mentioned before so one of the things
that I think is unique about what we do
is quantitative analysis but also
collection techniques or different types
of collection techniques so the Getty is
one example of an interesting collection
technique in that we scrape data off of
a database but we also draw from other
types other fields for collection
techniques and so we draw from computer
science and geography again
this project in Beijing we created air
quality sensors that collect information
about air quality by place and so as
you're moving through the city you're
collecting different air quality
information so this is actually Jen's
path one day with the air quality sensor
that we created for her and this is
another path that she took one day and
we hooked these up with a cell phone
technology so that once the data is
collected by the GPS in air quality it's
submitted back to main server using SMS
message technology or cell phone
technology and the sensors use GPS
devices and this is a particulate matter
sensor and one of the things that we did
in this project would really measure
smog and we looked at the particles
during the Beijing Olympics and so the
way that this works is similar in that
you collect the X&Y coordinate by time
and then this is actually a reading of
the CEO at that time and so the data
base is then translated spatially these
maps were featured in the New York Times
this is actually during the Beijing
Olympics they put in a reduction of cars
on the road so some days had if your
license plate had an even number you
would be on the road and if you had an
odd number this is before the car
mandate was put in place this was after
so you saw some decrease in carbon
emissions and this is new york for the
same time so we were able to use the
device to follow and this is the
marathon route to get an idea how the
athletes might feel as they run along
the limpid route so when we found with
the carbon admissions data is that air
quality for carbon improved but we
actually found that
we also did another reading at the
Olympic Park tenement square in the
temple of heaven and we found readings
that were much higher for particulate
matter
so the enforcement for cars helped with
carbon emissions but particular matter
was still very high so the red here is
actually showing you particulate matter
and you can see in some cases it's you
know 20 times higher than it would be in
New York is yellow and London is orange
this is the World Health Organization
standards for developing countries right
here you can see how much higher the
particulate matter was and this is the
AMA Beck start I mean actually see the
during the track and field events and I
don't know if anybody remember the
Olympics but it was raining a lot during
that time and so that's why the levels
are much lower during that and data can
be quantitative but it can also be
visual so we took images every day and
so these images are a part of our what
we consider data when we talk about the
lab being focused on data but you can
see on opening day it was a particular
matter was 13 times higher than it was
in New York City but in some cases it
was actually lower and there's lots of
speculation of why that is and one of
the speculations is that the Chinese
government was actually seeding the
clouds during the last week to - if it
rains and the particulate matter would
actually come down the ground but those
are speculation visualization is also
another component of kind of how we
think are our methods and we really draw
I think also from art design and I
always put geography because there's
kind of a history of cartographic
representation that comes out of
geography which I think very much
relates to art and design and so in this
project the million dollar blocks
project we took data about where
prisoners live before they went to
prison
and we're able to map those data and
quantify how much money was being spent
each year to incarcerate people by city
block so the red dots red block show you
where over a million dollars was spent
to incarcerate prisoners from one year
and if you look at this one community
you can see that these twelve blocks
have over 12 million dollars spent on
them in one year but they also lack a
lot of city services and through a
project like that we actually worked on
its another method that I would say is
kind of more urban planning scenario
planning where we've brought together
people that would think about this
community and this is Brownsville in New
York and we asked them to think about
different strategies that they might
think in architectural representation
that could help alleviate I mean if you
have 1 million dollars to spend on this
community how would you spend it it's
basically that question and we brought
people from the community together to
ask this question we used more
traditional data set here census data
and government data to look at community
district 16 to say to kind of explore
what is going on there along with
community members criminal justice
activists and so forth and we had food
stamp recipients violent crime inference
pro information general information and
population remove since 1985 people of
color and so forth and we asked people
to come together and think about the
data was there in the community and what
changes might be facilitated by that and
from that we created a series of
pamphlets that talked about
possibilities for policy for re-entry
programs so another
my final project I think I'm getting
close on my time here is I think we draw
some of our work from social media and
again this is kind of I think some of
the methods we use here or borrow from
computer science and geography and this
project the cripple bush ghost tour we
were interested in the names behind
plays and how to expose that and a
different type of way so in this project
if you came across a sticker I told you
why a particular street was named
something or a park in this case the
ghost of John and James Laura Graham
lawyers and local real estate
speculators in the 1830s was less than
savvy reputation so we wanted to kind of
think about how you can expose place
through a different type of technology
so we did a series of research where we
looked at the names behind certain
places in Williamsburg so we found out
what Leonard Street was named what
Roebling Street was Macri Square and we
put those together and we put stickers
up across the neighborhood that said a
ghost lives here and text this phone
number or text this number to this phone
number and the result is on people's
phones you would find out the various
people who live there so on Aynsley
Street it was a local judge of school
district trustee in 1847 one of the 44
people in town with a net worth of over
$10,000 a lot of money back then um and
we put these all over Williamsburg and
people texted in and we log that into a
database and people responded in really
interesting ways I think this one was
pretty interesting we're watching out
for you I'm in black morning class there
was always I've admired your work on the
bridge miss Roebling we
Emily Roebling sticker so she was one of
the guests on the tour so and we were
able to use the data behind the text
messages to begin to create maps about
where people texted what were they
interested in and so forth and so it
started to give us a a better idea of
how people observe space because what we
found is their particular locations
where people texted more weren't more
interested in more tips things and but
what we also found from the project is
people want to participate and they want
to send their information back in some
way and so when they got a response they
wanted to respond back so we got a lot
of information that way so the finalize
my talk today I think at the core of
what the lab does is really think about
data can expose different social
environmental issues and the lab
brower's methods from social science
computer science social media
geography architecture and art and
design and our strengths as researchers
is in our ability to combine hard
statistical quantitative methods with
visualization strategies
howdy so I'm just gonna set this up
okay
hi everyone my name is mother and I'm
I'm the director of milk which is moving
in each lab at Columbia and this is
Mabel it's has already explained there
so what the lab is interested in doing
is exploring the relationship between
the various forms of the moving image
and architecture and design so what it
produces is short form works of
animation fictional narrative
documentary and some interactive content
and the concerns of the lab may seem a
little bit peripheral at first but I
would argue that the interests are
actually quite central to architecture
and design and hopefully that'll be
illustrated through some of the work
that's presented and I mean that not
just within the Academy but also within
the practice as well so I'll provide
some context to explain all this
historically we can map the relationship
between the movie image and architecture
arguably back to the Renaissance but in
a more recent history the lab with a
more recent history the lab is interest
in the kind of work that's been
championed by architectural figures like
the Eames and super studio and I want to
be quite specific here because there are
a large number of architectural
academics and practitioners that are
interested in film and cinema but then
there are also a lot of so for example
Greg Lynn and to me just to talk about
some that are within our Columbia
community but then there are also a lot
of filmmakers that are interested in
architecture like Spielberg and
Eisenstein that were influenced by the
work here and AZ so but what needs to be
said is that both of these sets of
practitioners in the end remain
operating in their own disciplines so
this is quite different
to the work that's privileged by the lab
where I cite examples like the ancient
super studio because they were
architects but they crossed over to
working as film makers and produced
films and animations and the Eames
produced over seventy and four super
studio their work was so over-the-top
that the only way they could explain it
was more through representations rather
than build work another reason is that
well today as as toros already talked
about with computing video is also
ubiquitous and with all our mobile
devices and the growing amount of video
content online and academic coursework
that is shifting to video and broadcast
forms and the thousands of cable
channels to suit every need I could go
on and on the question that arises in
the end is you know how can we afford
not to explore what all this means for
architecture and there's certainly a
number of architecture schools I'd say
the majority that have some underlying
interest or a professor or a design
studio if it's worked into the
curriculum that does engage in this
relationship between film and
architecture or other works of moving
image but I haven't really come across
many places that are looking at it very
critically that have been trying to
explore what that actually means deeply
so I'm going to show you a couple of
examples of the work and describe why we
call that research as kate has and
jeanette have talked about I agree it is
incredibly important to talk about the
shoulders and people that you stand on
none of this work it's created by you
know in in a vacuum or in isolation and
so at the moment so there's a number of
things so looking for milk out you know
of course have a relation
with the school and a lot of the the
knowledge that sort of created gets
shared back through the visionary
methods of practice of course that I run
and then so then there's places like
within columbia like the Earth Institute
where we're currently working on a
project which is called the Federation
Map Room and and then their schools a
whole other design school patterns that
we're working with as well
this isn't I don't see this in any way
as a conflict of interest in terms of
which score we privilege it's more
really about that it offers an
intellectual plurality that you know
because there are some things that can
be done at Parsons that can't be done
here and some of the things that here
they can't be done there and then
there's various projects that have come
through that we're currently involved in
with NGO organizations like the Red
Cross and Oxfam and the government
Ethiopia as well as commercial companies
like Swiss Re officers here and like LTL
and and and I'm just gonna speak today
about two of the projects which is
cities of preference and the park tower
animation but before I do I think it's
worth professing those with the labs
research agenda just to lay out some
ground work and I once heard research
described very immediately with this
diagram and that is that on the one side
of this line is everything that we know
and on the other side is everything that
we don't know and this is us you me
everyone and the point of research is to
be able to push this line further into
the unknown this is a very simple and at
the most generic level of talking about
research across all disciplines not just
within architect
and so in looking more specifically at
what the labs trying to do now there are
basically two forms of paradigms of
research if you like that a privilege
within the Academy and that is the model
adopted by the sciences so largely
qualitative and and then the model by
the humanities which is sorry Sciences
in quantitative and objective and the
humanities being qualitative and
subjective this is you know an
epistemological concern about different
ways of knowing so you know if we talk
about what's known and what's unknown
then we really have to talk about how do
we actually come to know something how
is knowledge actually created and you
know these two what generally being you
know considered as dichotomies do leave
out a lot of other things where
invention actually happens and so
because in the lab what's created is
actual work films animations and so on
it doesn't we don't really explore
things technically about films through
numbers nor do we write about films you
know with texts and create articles we
make work and so it means that through
the making we're also exploring and
demonstrating the discoveries so this
really is about a third paradigm of
research that we could probably fit
release this conversation called design
research so what it argues about what's
argued here is that the practice of
design is in itself an inquiry asking
questions that lead to discoveries which
make a contribution to the field that is
just as significant as those pursued by
the other paradigms of research as
pushed by the sciences and the
humanities so the lab has adopted a
project-based model of research so let's
have a look at a couple of those
projects so the first one is the park
tower which is done with Lewis Suribachi
Louis I'm not sure how many of you might
be familiar with the work of LTL I'm not
going to go into the project so much I'm
just going to really truncate a lot of
the research that was surrounding this
to just talk about a couple of aspects
but I'll just mention what this project
is this is the park tower which is a
speculative design project for the
Venice Biennale some years back and it's
a double helix and it was looking at car
parking and one helix is all car park
and the other helix that's wrapped in it
it's all program that's probably enough
to mention because what was really the
focus of this project was that the
representational technique that ltl used
to create they work so you know there's
there was a period probably not so much
now but maybe perhaps in the late 90s
when you could open up an atlas of you
know architectural work and realize that
the representations reflected certain
practitioners bizarre house paintings
were identified leaves our hearts leave
our skins drawings and models were
identified Lee Lee the skins an LTL have
been quite ambitious in creating their
own representational technique which
reflects their agenda and it's kind of
well it's complicated in that it takes a
while to do them so this is a really
really large drawing I think it's about
the size of that table in the end where
to create an image it's first it's
modeled up really sort of simply and
crudely without too much detail and then
rendered with just a single light source
and then it's printed out or plotted out
in this case and traced over by hand
and then you get these really beautiful
markings like Knights crossing over each
other's smudges mistakes that you rub
and kind of well the smudges that
created with the hand over the pencil
them as the lid gets smeared and then on
top of that these things are scanned in
and photographic content is laid on top
so we've got a rendering drawing
photographic content to basically end up
with sometimes these drawings take a
week sometimes they take several weeks
now for the studio it's it's you know
the work is often I think quite
beautiful that comes out quite laborious
but then how would it actually migrate
over to animation and so the problem was
you can't draw every single frame like
this so another technique had to be
developed and so we wanted to find a
sort of digital technique that could
that could replicate this at it
aesthetic and continue this identifiable
representational practice into animation
for the student so it was originally
followed the same structure of sort of
compositing but entirely in a digital
way where a scene was renderer rendered
out in multiple parts with wireframe
lighting different objects and smudges
all sorts of things and so that in the
end composited together you'd get all
these sort of similar attributes so
you'd get the smudges and the hand
markings and the scratches you'd get the
ink blotting together when it's over
drawn and you get lines that cross over
each other and fade off as well but to
animate a project isn't merely about
making a drawing move it brings up all
other sorts of things suddenly you have
to think about narrative you have to
think about character development you
have to think about sound design how the
characters how the character actually
arcs over the whole over the whole
animation so a lot of time was spent
actually scripting a narrative that was
very specific to this
object I'm just going to show you a
quick 30 second clip that the final
animation is about eight minutes this is
without any sound I'm just going to talk
over the top of it but the idea was can
we in each frame be able to maintain
that representational aesthetic that ltl
do but at the same time bring out a
narrative that reflects the interests
and the concerns of the office that are
specific to that office and at the same
time describes something that is about
unique about architectural practice and
on top of that find very specific
moments or qualities about that
particular project the park tower
project
and weave that back into the narrative
so in this case it was about two people
that were caught on different each of
the each other one caught on a different
helix and we're trying to meet each
other and the other project is the
documentary cities of preferences that
we just finished a while back late last
year and it's was commissioned by the
sub curators of the architecture
Biennale in Rotterdam Interborough and I
had co-directed this piece with two
former students from here
Andrea's illowsky I mean sorry one
student from here and here's a Lasky
another student from Europe that I've
taught him that I've taught and it was
initially the brief was initially can we
make a short documentary or an article
about this person and the work of this
person who is Thomas Schelling and it
was a 2005 Nobel laureate for economics
he's done an extraordinary amount of
work and was kind enough to invite us
into his house for wine and cheese and
he told us about the stuff that we were
interested in he's worked at the White
House with Kennedy done incredible
things the thing that we were
particularly interested in was there in
the late 60s he developed a model which
is called the shelling city
a shoe model which described how
neighborhoods become segregated and he
developed it with his nine-year-old son
at the time on a chess board using
different coins I won't go into it in
too much detail but he explains it in
his book and it's been cited by a lot of
people anthropologists computer
scientists economists policymakers as
helping explain one of those very
unexplainable things but the problem was
when we were trying to when we were
looking at it was that it was too
abstract it was too diagrammatic and we
couldn't actually find an ideal way of
representing it and so we explored it
partly through animation so how do we
actually set this diagram back in the
street and and build it up but then we
also wanted to in creating a documentary
about it not just do this as a kind of
report a journalism report on the
showing segregation model but actually
make a full sort of over you know a full
arc in terms of a narrative and so we
interviewed anthropologists and
architects to talk about what is what
does it mean to be part of segregation
or how does segregation occur and when
is it congregation rather than
segregation and when they do occur what
when is it positive and when is it
negative and so I'll just play a little
clip
just Touche
hopefully we've got sound
I'm gonna try and just put the mic if
there's someone in the back room could
you
New York cities of like shelling
describes only in Reverse he describes
the kind of integrated checkerboard that
through his modeling becomes a
segregated model the the immigrant in
the city is an individual who comes and
then calls his family back in the old
country and she comes in an enclave
grows or around in a few pioneers so the
neighborhood's grow by association and
familiarity and that's what produces
this incredible mosaic
we are
Chinatown was most originally a male
population that were the cooks of
inlanders and you know very specific
tasks for New York and for a long time
it was well established in the Mott
Street Bell Street area that it is
centered on today and but didn't grow
too much for a long time but American
immigration laws changed because the
previous laws gave preference to
immigrants from Europe and there was a
rewriting of that law to open up
immigration policy
so the preference for immigration was
transferred to family connection and so
what you see is exactly what I said the
sort of family tie who you know becomes
the way a neighborhood grows and that's
when Chinatown editable
I have heard very interesting research
and papers actually about the
exploitation of the
Chinese immigrants by Chinese because
you know the language difficulties
actually encouraging people not to be
American not to learn English not to
know their rights they can be great
docile workers the restaurants and the
business is that the original Chinese
within Chinatown of course you know
there is a certain economic dynamism
that comes out of various forms of
illicit or illegal activities that keep
it dynamic in one sense while also
presenting this other face to
the rest in the city well under
conditions of the celebration of
multiculturalism becomes a place where
people from all over the city can go
there right but only for certain kinds
of activities Harlem was a real estate
project that failed it was middle-class
brownstone developments that were
introduced in the wrong economic climate
and they had to find tenants and they
were willing to even accept African
American tenants in their in their new
development the Harlem Renaissance was
created
and now today I was struggling to
maintain african-american neighborhood
because of course it's a you know
accessible attractive religion has been
undergoing the most extreme change and
and with Columbia nurse expanding to
West Harlem then
incredible gentrification and new
construction going on
a huge
demographic so I won't talk about all
the sleep things specifically just
really try stuff highlight the
differences of you know what we were
actually asking when we made the work
what were the discoveries that were made
and who was a really better serve in the
end because I think it's the thing about
you know why do we actually do research
well what good is it if we can't
actually share it with other people and
I think the having a lab certainly
allows for a number of things to happen
and it's worth talking about the
potential of each lab as this in-between
space between practice and the Academy
where our students are able to also get
involved in in different ways it's
something I think will start to go into
in more detail
so the idea is to be able to open up
just start a conversation off and then
you know ten minutes into it open it up
to the audience and have you ask
questions directly thank you
okay so everyone can hear me okay great
I think it might be worth just for the
benefit of all the students that are
here to perhaps talk about if maybe each
of us could talk about how students
actually get involved in the labs what
they do specifically because I think
it's a given that we all teach courses
here and that's one way to come across
the same body of knowledge but then
obviously the lab should offer something
else something different too taking a
studio or a seminar so perhaps we could
just illustrate that to everyone just
what exactly it is that people get
involved in when they are taking get
involved with the lives
yeah after we have I have four students
we're interested in research information
one of the great things about working in
the lab is you would say for us as we
follow a lot of different models of
research I think it really depends on
the project if it's I think we've had
some really amazing people work with us
in the past year especially I mean
that's really when we started me to say
but some we really started to work with
people like that and I think it runs the
range from larger projects where we
really are working as a team and kind of
you know we're working for example to
make the table that was in the studio X
show or working to kind of broadcast the
podcasts of the maps
so I think in that way we work in a very
coordinated way in other ways
there have been projects that we've
worked on that are really student-led
one example that comes to mind is the
website we have this page called the
urban landscape encyclopedia that was
started by Evan sharp and that was
definitely his project that he started
and kids continued to maintain and it's
been really great to see
his own interpretation of the lab and
its potential come out of that so I
think we're interested in all sorts of
ranges of involvement just especially in
the case of with the safari seven tours
and you Jeanette gave these great
examples with the safari seven tours I
think we definitely have opportunities
for sort of you know strategic strike
interactions like if you have a free
weekend definitely have opportunities
for interaction and and on the other
hand it's very exciting for us to think
about having longer-term inter you know
relationships with an AR students
student or students in the sense of kind
of taking something and really seeing it
all the way through based on your your
expertise and your knowledge and so I
guess it's really that dynamic between
the the weekend warrior and the sort of
year-long exploration
I guess the the fabrication that we have
there are some classes that are
specifically related to digital
fabrication and then studios and some
people just bring work to do in the lab
we also have connections through
projects or so on that happen and so
sometimes the students that work they're
coming from someplace and we do over the
summer where we advertise and so on but
there are an occasion you know very
small I didn't show a lot of the smaller
projects but just a student or to come
up with an idea that's about as much
morgan ization as it actually it takes
right so there's a wide variety of ways
that since our cloud lab just started
and get the students but somewhat for us
it's definitely this kind of awareness
of this front the kind of new space
filtering right I mean obviously we've
horizontally connect a lot right like a
lot of data media resources and not to
kind of split hairs that I think we all
kind of reach this point where there's
all this there's this new front of kind
of spatial let's say terrain that's
somewhat opening so fast that we don't
even see the edge and we're just kind of
jumping in at least for our end I think
to even develop a software it's not
somewhat of a you know a quick
turnaround so I do see as a kind of long
term project and especially in the kind
of community of like developing
I think the kind of culture in software
development is that you kind of extend a
previous research so if there's anything
that we would distinct from running a
studio is that it kind of extends the
previous so the research doesn't get
lost
usually with studios one body keeps one
projects and goes to the next so even
though the professor may have an agenda
the body of knowledge is somewhat lost
but I think what these labs the beauty
of it is that there's a kind of growing
knowledge in every of them and the
moment that you kind of participate in
any of these is that you already have a
reservoir of knowledge that you can tap
into and you're there to kind of extend
it so as much as there's not much on the
table for the cloud lab it is already
open to that kind of context because
whoever is directing the lab I think for
futures I think directors start changing
too and there is this kind of consistent
agency of the laboratory but not the
director so the directors could change
or perhaps shouldn't change the point
the kind of platform is not so much
there's this kind of director meeting
something but it is a kind of big kind
of platform for things to develop
further so there's a knowledge that's
kept in the lab the laboratory that Kent
gets extended by more students and the
participation length can vary
could be a whole year I think that scale
is kind of dependent on the kind of
project just to kind of answer my own
question at least my own though I think
there's being three types of work three
different ways that students have got
involved in the work so there's been the
lab initiated project we've conceived of
one and then people into the involved
there's the other kind which is that
it's externally asked of us
so like the cities' of preferences and
then there's the there's another example
of a project which I didn't show today
but a student Cheryl Wong who I've
taught in the past approached me
afterwards and said I'd like to do an
independent study you know can this come
through and and we've worked on it and
it's something that the independent
study has officially finished in for
academic purposes but we're still
working on the film it's ongoing and for
her it's just a way being out of
authored work that couldn't really
happen anywhere else and looking at the
work in all three ways they have very
different values in terms of the people
that they're supposed to speak to and as
Tora mentioned the kind of the agency of
them and that's I think a really
interesting point to actually talk about
because I think in today's presentation
what presentations what's come up is
that it's it's probably not it wasn't
made so clear and deliberate but I think
it is an under the surface so I'd like
to ask everyone to kind of talk about it
but really for each of us to describe
what the agency of our work is
- I mean I could sort of meet
presumptuous and say you know Sarah and
Kaitlyn Jeanette your work you know
you've already talked about the way that
it started to influence policy for
example and has these sort of what you
know talks to these other communities
that we don't often engage directly and
Tauro
you know you I always thought that a lot
of the work that you've done and having
known you work over the years it's
really so much about it's a bit hard to
say but it's more more about looking at
different types of practices as well
amongst other things and charting out
new terrain of well if all this stuff is
happening then surely there are these
spaces being created and opportunities
for new types of studios and a way of
practicing and I think for what fill lab
the Fab Lab and my lab would have in
common is that it's really learning
through making so making films or making
actual objects that that's where the
learning and the research and discovery
is actually made but again I don't want
to be too presumptuous it's more just to
kind of get the ball rolling about if
you could talk about where you've had
the most influence where you believe the
kind of nature from mark and I that we
already opens this kind of notion of
you're designing an application so
application somewhat focuses really
clearly who your audience is and like
what the kind of software should be
doing so some what the audience is
somewhat clear and who the user is clear
and I think that's
just coming from this kind of background
of coding it implies that kind of nature
so and just to kind of answer that I
think more so for you know what what
what is kind of opening up this is
really just again I repeatedly say this
kind of new form of practice is that
it's really ubiquitous like you can
change one day of literally filming or
algorithmically making a film all of a
sudden that data can be transformed to a
certain individual that communicates
radically across many people at the same
time so the agency is not so much about
the kind of the kind of lab but it's the
agency of that one person is so large
now that can reach so diversity to so
many people I think that's that still
kind of remains many people right now I
think especially for like an
architectural practice since some what's
considered the kind of global brain
right that we know so many things that
once that that kind of ties to this kind
of agency I think we have the most
I would just say one of the things that
is exciting for me about the lab concept
too is that you're not necessarily
thinking about the receivers of the
information as you are conceptualizing
it and when Janette and Glenn tonight
sat down and we were brainstorming about
what eventually became safari 7 it
wasn't it had so much you know now that
we have made it has so many aspects or
different audiences that have
essentially discovered it but I think
that's one of the great things about the
lab format is that it's basically to
some degree an experimentation based on
a set of concepts or shared ideas and
and that somehow that that finds its own
voice or it finds its own audience and
the same thing with the bird the bird
guidelines came out of basically like
volunteering with the Audubon Society
and then kind of finding something that
was there and that could be expressed
and then that and it turned from its own
audience in a sort of likeliness of the
kind of green building industry but it
seems like that that's something that is
particularly exciting to me
basically becomes a way for us to
establish the projects that we want to
start doing and kind of be advocates for
what it is that designers do best
it's
it's a similar way we're in the
fabrication that because typically when
you're constructing something you do
have a client right and you have
somebody to answer to for certain things
this allows us
it's chilled but it's also usually
research that comes you know from
another person it's one of the things
that we're trying to do is effect change
I think highlight underlying cards in
the community that might help but I
think on the other side we have a
research community that's interested
new forms of data and there's growing
community that's thinking about how can
we use crowd-sourced data or how can we
use data that's collected on the web and
what are we different what can we say
about it scientifically and I think so I
think our projects also have that as an
agent so we're writing in developing
papers for those journals well at the
same time as thinking about how we can
use our visualizations to tell us the
story about place yeah but I'm not sure
how many people actually know how the
labs started and drives them but it
really was because there were a large
number of teaching faculty adjuncts that
we're doing really interesting things
but they were only teaching a couple of
courses here and so they had a very
limited capacity in which in how they
could engage with the school and so the
labs were set up as this kind of middle
ground between practice
as well and being able to do things that
didn't fit in the curriculum and so if
you look at it the labs have a very
interesting place because at the school
here we have coursework masters and then
we have a ph.d program which is largely
thesis or policy raised but there's
nothing that's kind of project centered
and so a lot of that's great projects
and I think I can probably say this that
for all of us it really begins with a
kind of an enthusiasm
and so you really do see how that stuff
enthusiasm can be sculpted
I mean there are groups there are
quantitative methodologies that really
require certain ways of working and
adherence to certain models in which and
they have specific names I mean you
describe very succinctly I am using this
particular method to basically work
through that data and I don't think
anybody else really said you know
there's this particular method and I was
curious given that architectural
methodologies a far more elastic in
terms of how it works how you found
working with kind of these quantitative
methods in relationship to other kinds
of methods working because you said
particularly like on the visualization
side you start to do with a whole other
kind of set of criteria right that
affects the work and it seems like
you're really negotiating I think that
and I think that's been really hard or
difficult given the kinds of education
that we have for architecture that's
what I think is very interesting and
that's what I wanted to know given you
know the survey of the labs how is that
inflecting back on educational models
because I think we're still trapped in a
much older model of Education about how
practice works and then I think practice
particularly through NAB is trying to
clamp down on the deliverables of the
degree but the reality of the field is
that practices are in fact diversifying
how they work so that you have in firms
research laboratories you know that are
operating and so what I think is very
interesting is that all of a sudden even
in practice you're getting these other
ways of working that are now there and
so how do we start to negotiate you know
and I think you Suzy represented exactly
kind of where that maybe future a
fracture actually is yeah I mean I think
for me I guess I was trained and both
method so it's easy for me represents
twice the amount of for almost two
projects right I mean I guess mic for it
if you take the Getty project for
example the amount of work it takes to
run you know science statistics and what
you would typically see in a geographic
geography paper is just that final chart
of the Marines I which isn't that
compelling and so I guess for me it's
really important to include the visuals
because I think it helps bring the
message to a larger so I think that's
why taking the quantitative and then
applying the visualization for me
because it brings the idea to more
people than have otherwise but I also
think in my teaching I have always
emphasized the need to think about the
quantitative and qualitative because if
you only approach a project in the
quantity this is my idea but I feel like
if you only approach something
quantitatively you're going to miss so I
think that GIS or different kinds of
spatial statistics programs help
highlight areas
concern or areas interest but it's the
qualitative information that really
layers that place and can tell us more
about one one question that kind of
probably is useful is you know the
measurement in in kind of recognizing
the kind of degree of innovation so
because all project is in some way or
another innovation right i kind of
iterated or evolved through a kind of
condition now the question is probably
for me once that's kind of I mean I've
heard to a certain degree architectural
education trains everyone to become kind
of entrepreneur innovator or I mean a
finger right finger constantly thinks of
the next situation now I think even
though that said the creations have a
fitness right somewhat is put into the
world and see what laughter what's more
recognized or there's a kind of degree
of evaluation now I think that process
is rarely discussed like we let the
fitness of the world kind of let our
things go right so we put it out there
and see we can mark it etc but to a
certain degree couldn't we even then I
mean doesn't that turn back and kind of
evaluate the projects in a sense so this
is the feedback part of like putting a
project up there and then you have a
version to version 3 someone like
software where there's always another
version sometimes like Autodesk it
becomes worse right but at least there's
a kind of iterative idea of like going
back to that project and what would be
different I think many cases of I guess
architecture
it's a one-off there's not a moment to
iterate but I think with researchers
there's the moment to iterate because
there is a kind of case of a topic I
think that's why because there's a
platform to identify something now the
success again I think that you'll have a
different iteration first so I think
that's kind of potentially what I see in
the lab is that there's an opportunity
to iterative project rather than not
being a one-off project that's the usual
architecture project become and again I
repeat that kind of notion of studio
projects also becoming a one-off the
other one case studio not having the
potential to iterate again so in this
laboratory I think it is an opportunity
when I say you extend the previous
knowledge is that you're kind of
refining it or iterating through
so I guess my question is I'm not sure
how many and I don't have a background
before architecture or I mean I know the
kid or you did landscape right
architecture and Sara you had one in
geography so I wonder how the kind of
research that you're doing now whether
weather is an X is it an extent
extension of something you that you had
prior like how do I say I know it's a
very research oriented but is it like an
extension of something you had prior
like in the discipline of landscape
architecture I did my undergrad in
landscape architecture and there's not
many projects when you would say that
are very similar to 47 at least in terms
of discipline and in geography there is
a history of I guess visualization but
now I'm not sure like how is it cutting
edge isms is it something different from
the discipline and is that influenced by
the kind of like by the mingling with
architecture I guess by that
I mean they're both that I mean the
design disciplines the same way but I'm
not sure like do your friends back in
like your undergraduate friends are they
doing the same thing
I think it raises a great question
question which is funky boundary that
exists you know that requires a
discipline to be coherent and have
standards
license and registration all the things
that are involved calling something a
discipline and then I think there's
what's so exciting about the lab is that
you're kind of not approaching things
through a disciplinary perspective of
course so I might look at something
differently but but I think that's what
is so exciting is that taking about the
lessons that you're coming at something
through the perspective organized where
I'm coming from in general so the lab is
a great forum I think it's particularly
I think there's always an
autobiographical elements Lamson because
we initiate them ourselves so we kind of
try to bring something unique that's
worth doing but the other thing is of
course you know I remember hearing a
statistic truth there is that for all
the accreditation
program has to jump through the skull
here is kind of interesting because at
least in the aad program people coming
here to get a masters that they don't
really need to in order to practice so
then it's all about saying well can we
explore all the things on the roof
because we know the things that
essential because we've already got
accreditation but then whilst you can do
all these things for us you know so some
people come here so that they're no
longer having so they can do things they
can't do it practice and this is
students but then at the same time we
then go and set up labs so we try and
occupy this sort of space where we can
try
I think that's you know so at the same
time you can go back and other times
it's a different type of way of looking
at which which is good because
I'll kind of say this one question just
because there's so few people you know
this question of like cutting edge or
innovation so I mean to rephrase that
question I'm questioning into myself
does innovation happen at this school
right is the school the real innovation
cutting edge just a question I mean
Columbia or institution in general right
like just just developing apps you know
for us it's part of our kind of
experimental you know terrain I mean
you'll have these crazy you know
twelve-year-old doing the YouTube
tutorial on making an app not that the
kind of tutorial part it's an important
part but the kind of in innovation can
happen so fast now in outside the school
that you know I think it's questioning
well how do we catch up or how do we
rethink the kind of role of innovation
so how does the school kind of think of
institution and really kind of gauge
that because the reality is the the real
kind of fitness function is outside
practice right I mean somehow there's
then the practice of you know PhDs in
like you know thesis statements with
kind of all this kind of other kind of
standards that things are evaluated now
that being separated I think can be
spoken that school institution because
there's a standard of measurement right
the right kind of did wrong or fee you
know facts they're aligned
to define the kind of paper but when I'm
not so kind of make the economic
measurement of the project the kind of
bar but I think the question of that you
know the innovation happened at the
school can you kind of mutate into what
are what are the standards are we
measuring all these projects by that's
kind of like if we take the academic
standards and we value I mean all
projects are so innovative but then we
go outside then have a different
standard broaden in measured it'll be a
different kind of evaluation so I think
that has to somewhat be clear somewhat I
mean maybe it's just a self kind of
clarification but at least that's an
issue that has to be discussed more as a
kind of institution because everything
is becoming more faster more you know
instantaneous we don't have time to wait
you know so seem to be kind of two parts
of that too because one is like what is
the role of institution to not just be
an institution
and then on the other hand you know how
I would say you know you had all these
charts I was impressed by your charts
you know like how does innovation happen
I'm sure there's like the particle
accelerator 50 years underground that
slack there's certainly another
methodology which is innovation happens
when people talk to each other
the economists and so you know I think
it's interesting to think how Columbia
you know how its succeeding in those
realms and I guess I'm just flashing
back to this question about the disc
disciplinarity because certainly that's
something that I think Columbia could
use a lot more because you know when you
are admired and the academic kind of
structure it does I'm sure everybody has
their own story at this table about
grant writing Sarah working with you
know Earth Institute and the sort of
difficulties that the sort of very real
tangible difficulties that happen I
would say both of those novels and so
and I would totally agree that the lab
isn't this kind of represents for me the
symbol even if it's not the actuality
there but this this notion where you
know these different models of
sharpening
it's definitely one one kind of designer
to that it's like computer science
becoming this obsolete department
because it's getting integrated to all
departments so you know medical biology
chemistry they just you absorb that and
discipline itself but just talking about
Turing machine it's just a crazy thing
you know I mean we only need a few
people for that right but I think that
just has to happen almost for all
disciplines in the sense that you know
architecture is about human body so we
should be doctors you know like the the
cross pollenization of the departments
almost happen has to happen like
computer science in the sense that you
know which which is this kind of cross
right if the focusing of that research
has been this kind of century of
institution because there was like
cutting up departments right you do
medicine you do biology it's actually
not true everything's interconnected so
in some ways we just have to break that
walls like I think that is the modern
time the specialist computation where
everything's becoming Flint everything
is like information is everywhere you
can access any kind of information and I
think it's gonna be the kind of future
institutions just you can't be divided
like that anymore and there has to be
broken sideways so maybe we should be I
mean even within the lab which should be
probably doing project sideways and
beyond that architecture school has to
be going to the music engineer and
really kind of not just oh I can take a
few courses but really integrating as a
curriculum what I would think is the
kind of future of like an institutional
power is that it's all there we just
have to break the wall with you cannot
gain outside of
you could tap into the Internet of
reservoir but it's not structured like
you have to structure yourself so the
beauty of the institution could be if it
breaks the sidewalls when it was
actually separated out and we just get
together we're gonna do it you know and
I think it's really important because
any five Economist's are going to
disagree with each other completely any
five architects are and I think
the arguing in front of Congress
the idea the way that architects
interpret implications of knowledge that
kind of can bridge like action and I
think so much of that you know not being
able to find the right grants things is
I don't think designers generally do a
very good job of demonstrating our
expertise other than just braiding good
work but we never actually share it
means to be if we could do that we would
I mean
right the idea being that if you can so
this is not just in making slideshows
look pretty but actually
so if we can find a way to kind of
demonstrate our expertise and share it I
think that this way to do that is for us
to be able to undertake research where
we can see its
I mean I just think that that these kind
of research labs are really offering
those opportunities for collaborations
across disciplines with other
professions and practice to produce new
bodies of knowledge through our as you
were suggesting mother our expertise and
I think given what's going to probably
happen at the other end of the shake-up
of the field that these are really kind
of critical models for how one works you
know even as a post graduate from this
institution so thank you